[Music]
I'm not going to make up my mind on
LeBron James or have a strong opinion on
the Bron James based on one game and you
guys also want to get rid of Isaiah
Thomas in Boston because Boston won last
night to bring in Reggie Aloysius Miller
reg part of the call last night he'll
have game for Eastern Conference Finals
tomorrow night the Celtics and Cavs with
Marv Albert and Chris Webber tip-off
8:30 Eastern on TNT reg when did you
realize something was up with LeBron we
had a shot of him during warmups and you
use the word uninspired but when he was
out there warming up and he had his
headphones in this is before you know
both teams actually took the floor you
know when he was there like two and a
half hours before he just kept shaking
his head because it didn't look like he
could find any rhythm and I think that
kind of translated to the game and it's
funny because you know you're right
people always just you know they say you
know what have you done for me lately
LeBron James has been fantastic in these
playoffs the guy has one bad game and
now they're ready to sail it see that's
why he wasn't on the you know the MVP
all you know MVP list going to New York
one bad game does not translate what
this man has done throughout his career
and during these playoffs
now surely he'll bounce back in Game
four and have a huge game and then
everyone will be patting them on his
back but you can't go by one game
especially in the playoffs I agree with
you that losses on LeBron James because
his teammates they showed up yeah if you
would have any type of effort from
LeBron James they win Game three but you
also have people saying to me today and
this is you know the reactionary sports
society that we live in all the Celtics
are better off without Isiah Thomas you
know I would assign him to a long term
contract I you know I
the Celtics you have to give them credit
with what they did and but I you know
it's one of those where you're kind of
going out nobody expects anything they
weren't dependent on anybody and they
played hard
and you know they pick up the wind but
why was Boston a different team without
Isiah Thomas well number one they made
shots and when you make shots you get
confident and they really weren't able
the Cavs to key in on one guy like
they've been doing in the first year
games with Isiah so you had Jae Crowder
you had Avery Bradley you had Marcus
smart who went crazy in that third
quarter making those threes and you had
al horford all consistently making shots
and that makes you a dangerous team and
really the cats had not one guy from
that Celtics team to really key on
because each of those guys I just
mentioned and then you throw in Jerebko
off the [ __ ] in Kelly Olynyk
all five of those guys made shots and
made key moments for that Celtics win so
look the same thing what I just said
about LeBron James is ridiculous for
Isaiah because I think you need to build
around Isaiah I think he's worth every
penny whenever he's asking for a big
long-term contract but he needs players
around him and last night the players
around him showed up in his absence to
steal that game three because it looked
like it was going towards games one and
two the way the Cavs were making shots
in that first half but if you listen to
some of the sound coming out of the
huddle from Brad Stevens he understood
his team wasn't playing hard and they
started to play hard and I said in that
fourth quarter the question is going to
be do they believe that they can beat
the Boston Celtics and that's when
Marcus smart made a couple threes and
they started to believe and they found a
way to win that ballgame yeah I give
Stephens a lot of credit because I don't
you know he knows that the odds are long
that they could win this series but he
was trying to win a game you can't win
the series unless you win a game and he
was saying look if we play hard we get
to the fourth quarter we have a chance
to win this game and you're thinking at
the time you know that's kind of cute
you know that's a college thing you
would say if you're at Butler now you're
trying to do that against the Cavs in
Cleveland and lo and behold they listen
to him and it's a young team and maybe
it was more of a collegiate aspect feel
to it that we're all in this and let's
you know somehow we'll find a way to win
well win or lose especially for a young
team you're in the you're in the
conference finals your best player is
done for the series and Isiah Thomas and
really you're playing with house money
right now because the pressure and the
expectations are for the Cleveland
Cavaliers the defending champions too
well to move on to LeBron James seven
straight NBA Finals so you're playing
with house money so why not go out and
play hard because the pressure really
isn't on you even though you're the
number one seed you got this young team
and your best player is out with a hip
injury so I think everyone stepped up
I'm glad that he played Jericho
you know Jericho's one of those those
players to kind of like the muck it up
you saw him talking trash just about
every child's player last night and they
kind of dirtied the game a little bit
but bottom line they made shots they
made threes I said coming into the
series they had to be someone even or
close to the Cavaliers and debris point
field goals made and they surpassed them
they off to a slow start but that third
quarter was great and their ability to
make three so they got their confidence
going forward can they win another game
I don't know maybe this is a wake-up
call for LeBron and the Cavs but their
confidence surely is back talking to
Reggie Miller and he's got Game four
coming up tomorrow night from Cleveland
Eastern Conference Finals with Marv
Albert and Chris Webber tipoff is at
8:30 a Kevin Durant part of a answer he
had to a reporter was and the reporter
saying you know these playoffs haven't
been very entertaining not very good and
you know Durant said then don't watch
them and what's taken a you know that
we're just going to focus on well then
don't watch them you know and Durant
doesn't come off very well when it says
hey just don't watch them but it's not
incumbent upon Durant to make this
interesting I mean they're trying to
make it not interesting and blow out
people I don't know if you saw that
quote from Durant or none well that's
the point of the job of the players you
know if I had the opportunity to blow
out my competition every single time I
took the floor I would take that route
as well you know
as a competitor you don't want the close
game that means you're doing your job
and because the Warriors have the
firepower that they have it's not their
job to make games close for the viewers
their jobs is the win ballgames by as
much as possible so I'm sure it's a
little frustration probably from that
reporter's point of view because you
know you want to see competitive games
but you know when you got the best teams
playing at a high level which we've seen
you know - last night from the Cavaliers
you can't fault blowouts you know that
that's they're there to do their jobs
their job is to win by as many points as
possible we haven't seen anything in
from Golden State where they had one
have one of those games like Cleveland
had last night where you go you just
sort of let this thing slip away you
know how it is this just something that
Cleveland still has in his DNA that you
know they can still have one of these
games out of these two teams Golden
State and Cleveland is the feeling that
Cleveland is more capable of doing this
obviously based off last night when they
get to the finals against one another
well we we've seen a couple of these
games from the Cavaliers to end the
regular season they were up 26 points at
half versus the Atlanta Hawks and let a
game slip away look both teams have
their faults I think turnovers at times
hurt the Golden State Warriors I think
they play too loose with the basketball
and they don't value possessions at
times but look these two teams are
clearly on a collision course towards
one another and I think you know there's
so many storylines with each team with
the addition of Kevin Durant for the
Golden State Warriors it being a trilogy
match both teams having won
championships there's been subtle jabs
and trash talk you know going back and
forth so look the storylines are there
but like there's still work to be done
you know there was a misstep last night
from the Cavaliers
you know they were up by as many as 21
and give all the credit as it should be
to the Boston South
by the way a way to win Game three and
for the Warriors they have one more you
know and here's the thing for the
Cavaliers you have two more games left
now where you risk a twinkle a hamstring
we saw you know Isiah Thomas out for the
rest of the series because of a hip hip
injury that's an extra game now you have
to play where potentially someone can
get hurt and that's the problem that's
why you have to take care of business
when it presents itself last night a
huge misstep for the Cavaliers Chris
Webber was with us last week and I said
who would he rather have on the floor
Kyle Korver you right now Wow Craig
Korver is really struggling from that
three well I just think he's not getting
great looks
well Webber said he would take you rich
oh my goodness well god bless god bless
us and he said you're in better shape
well I haven't shaved but Korver has a
better trigger finger right now right
now you just need to get better looks
because they need that they need his
shooting off the bench and he's just
taking some some awful shot it is not
getting any clean look this thing I
brought this up when the all-nba team
came out that this was supposed to be
the like the anti Kevin Durant rule that
this was going to benefit players and
the is going to benefit the teams as
well they were going to be able to keep
their players or offer them more money
but it feels like this is backfired now
with Paul George okay and Brandon yes
that that now they're not going to get a
max deal so now it's there's not that
big disparity here so this is working
against the teams in the so-called Kevin
Durant rule isn't it it's almost like
you're penalizing the player because it
I've never been a big fan of leading 30
million dollars on the table in the
hands of the media you know there's
certain media out there that you know
they might have an axe to grind so it's
unfortunate and you're right because now
it does look like it's going to backfire
because
as much as I don't want to see this as
much as it would hurt me to see Paul
George leave Indiana because that would
be a crushing blow to a small market and
because he's one of the top 10 players
in the league I don't I can't see that
happening but she got Magic Johnson and
the Lakers on the line calling thing you
could resurrect and Annie grew up in
California be a huge Kobe Bryant fan it
would crush me seriously it would crush
me as a fan to see Paul George leave but
I could see it now and going away if you
want to make that team 210 million
there's no way he's going anywhere
true but now I mean off the court money
in Los Angeles as well I could see it I
could see hey we're going to Boston what
are you doing on your off day I might
take the crew bowling all these guys
work really hard the camera guys and
producers and directors I want to take
the guys bowling we're going to go out
and you know check out game for the San
Antonio Spurs and go to state we'll go
bowling and have some fun here in good
old Cleveland yeah all right
you think let me go check out the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame
tell me three bands tell me three bands
or artists that I should check out at
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame I think
coming through the John Lennon exhibit
now I don't know if it's still there but
the John Lennon exhibit that I saw they
had the glasses they had on when he was
shot like Yoko
donated all of this stuff with John
Lennon that was pretty impressive that's
awesome number one definitely that's
great oh I think Elvis has some really
cool like the outfits that they wear are
pretty cool I don't know about the
Michael Jackson one because I know that
that's what you want to see I don't I
don't remember seeing the Michael
Jackson exhibit it's gotta be there
though you know yeah you think they
would have an MJ exhibit there correct
oh yeah oh yeah what would you pay for
Michaels glove Oh like I do have a hat I
have one of those hats that he doesn't
Billie Jean so I do have one of those
side so why did know it was my
retirement gift
you got another tire for the Pacers Mike
Jackson here Michael Jackson had and I
look at it every day and this is a glass
but I look at it every single day and
think I've got one of the greatest
artifacts ever I love it I love it yeah
I take that over like I have a dear J
Michael Jordan John Jersey
well I got Michael Jackson is above that
okay whoo that's right at who had a
greater career why are you doing this to
me why are you doing this to me but I
will say Michael Jackson yeah start at
five come on yeah yeah have fun enjoy
the bowling there with the boys and
we'll be listening tomorrow night you
are the best viewed or my Danny hey
separate yourself the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience